Percy the stories I have told you about
great Gods and
Monsters they are real Percy Jackson and
the Olympians has been one of the most
popular children's literature series
over the past 15 years and now it's a TV
series on Disney plus and from books to
movies to a series there's a little bit
to unpack here so we're going to tell
you everything you need to know before
the show Percy Jackson and the Olympians
lands on your viewing radar Percy
Jackson we've been expecting you okay so
here's what we're going to cover for you
today a little history on Percy in book
form Percy in movie form and then Percy
in series form it's basically going to
be like a butterfly metamorphosis we're
also going to tell you about the cast
and the crew who made this new adventure
happen it is all coming up right now on
no before the show so here we go you
know just don't be slow just go with the
flow sorry I can't help myself we need
to go so just to give you a quick
rundown about where this franchise all
started Percy Jackson and the Olympia is
a series of fantasy novels first
published in 2005 with a six installment
that came this year and another one
coming in 2024 they were all written by
Rick Ryan and they're all set in a world
with Greek gods but in the 21st century
Percy is a young tween demigod who has
pretty much been tasked with saving the
world from something called the Titans
led by Kronos which sounds a little bit
like the Disney animated Hercules meets
Marvel and that makes sense considering
people love those entities and Percy
Jackson has sold nearly 200 million
books worldwide that's a lot of eyeballs
BT Dove there's also two prequel book
series and some other related short
stories as well so if this new show is
popular you already know that there is
more where that came from and because
adapting popular books is nothing new
there have been two big budget movies
made from the books the first one
happened in 2010 with the rotten Percy
Jackson the Olympians the Lightning
Thief starring Logan lurman and
Alexandra didario now it got decent box
office numbers but ultimately rubbed
fans the wrong way that movie was
followed up by 2013's Percy Jackson Sea
of Monsters also starring lurman andario
and also rotten on the Tomato Meter fans
were once again not feeling it largely
due to deviations from The Source
material so needless to say plans for a
third film were scrapped after that it
is worth noting though that the book's
author Rick was not involved in those
movies he didn't really care for that
much like the fans of the book so he
made sure to be involved this time
around for the show but now that you
know about the book and movie versions
here's Percy as a big budget TV series
so when the show was first announced
Rick and wife Rebecca ryen also a
producer I mean talk about a power
couple released a statement saying how
excited they were to do a live action
series quote of the highest quality
adding that it's going to start with the
first book The Lightning Thief in season
1 and then Rick seemingly tried to put
fans at ease by suggesting that this
adaptation will be closer to the books
saying rest assured that Becky and I
will be involved in person in every
aspect of the show we love to see it so
in the first season we should expect to
see a young Percy discovering his
demigod status figuring out his power
and also trying to clear his name after
Zeus accuses Percy of stealing his
master lightning bolt I've heard of
stealing someone's Thunder before but
apparently that's so last year so
cealing lightning is in with a mix of
young and Veteran actors here's who
we're going to see acting it all out
along with Walker scoel as Percy we're
also going to meet his two partners in
demig godness now that includes Grover
Underwood played by Arian simadre who in
the books is a forest spirit with a
human torso and then there's Annabeth
Chase a daughter of Athena played by
Leah Savvy Jeff other casts you can
expect to see includes Virginia Cole as
Percy's mom plus characters played by
Megan malali Jason manukas Lin Manuel
Miranda and the late Lance reic who
plays Zeus in his final TV appearance
before his passing back in March RP
Lance now when it comes to the people
behind the scenes along with Rick Ryan
the series was co-created by Jonathan e
Steinberg he's helped bring a couple
different shows to life in the past
including cbs's Jericho and black sales
on stars now together they wrote much of
the first season and we know that
director James bobin helmed the first
two episodes you haven't heard of James
he helped create the famous Sasha Baron
Cohen characters Ali G Borat and Bruno
and he's directed movies like The
Muppets and Alice Through the Looking
Glass I mean what an eclectically cool
resume so friends there you have it that
is everything you need to know before
you watch Percy Jackson and the
Olympians when it hits Disney Plus on
December 20th it is going to be epic and
I'm very curious as to what you guys are
all going to think about it I'm Nas
Perez thanks for watching and be sure to
rate and review this show at Rotten
tomatoes.com
[Music]